vous publiez les mémoires d'un lion chez
perrin moi j'avais lu la rage de
convaincre des certaines histoires qui
était déjà dans la rage de convaincre
faut bien le dire n'est simple une
partie pas vraiment les mêmes faits
racontés avec l'indifférence ferry dix
ans d'écart entre lui et qu'aujourd'hui
je me trouvais un âge où on peut se
pencher sur ce qu'on n'a pas fait et vu
dans l'écrit pas pour eux je suis pas
vendeur je ne cherche pas à faire j'ai
eu beau ça marche très bien mais je ne
suis pas écrivain de la tuerait mais
j'aime la vie les cantonales la vie elle
vous aime vous n'aimez pas ne vous aime
pas jeter a tous les atouts ce qu'ils
font là ouais faut aimer la vie pour
prochain salon d'obstacles qui pour
certains ne passent pas le cours d'eau
des bois pas je suis de ceux-là
moi j'aime bien parce que c'est un peu
les belles histoires de l'oncle marcel
quoi ton âge c'est une très belle
histoire j'aimerais vous la raconte y
est parce que moi je trouve ça très fort
dans votre livre c'est quand vous vous
cherchez à avoir un faux passeport
et puis on ne pouvait pas vous appelez
bleustein passé la guerre racontez nous
cette histoire alors en deux mots sans
vous voulez bien je faisais partie d'un
réseau britannique
parce que les restos britannique était
particulier bien longue et lycées en
france on avait ce qu'on pouvait mais le
il avait une technique est faible seuls
espionnage en angleterre mais bien connu
et je me suis trouvé à la faire une
mission et je savais que j'avais été
repérés par les allemands donc je m'en
aille à tout prix j'ai des prévenus par
le réseau qu'il fallait partir du 11 mai
pour partir on peut prendre des trains
ou les voitures il y avait ni voiture et
lettres étaient sans arrêts contrôlés
par les jeunes
alors j'étais désespéré mais comme
j'étais pilote pendant la guerre le 39
49 40
j'ai mis mon vieux club cuir l'aviation
qu'elle est spéciale qu'on avait un
thuya particulier et je savais qu'ils
avaient lé commandant qu'il gardait le
camp de presles aix les bains vous les
avions étaient là ne pouvait plus voler
et à 2 heures du matin je suis arrivé
jusque chez lui
et puis j'ai frappé j'ai essayé la
valascia look était la cma hurlait je
suis pris de panique et un homme qui
sort qui me dis qu'est ce que vous
voulez a expliqué dans la nuit et je
suis pilote et je tiens à vous voir vous
êtes le commandant intel j'ai une
relation pour vous à la rentrée et
montures avec les verts d'aviation avait
compté tu m'aimes bas et je mexplique
matricule à sion g ou suis arrêté vous
me fabriqué les faux papiers
vous commandez le camp l'aviation il
faut vous les bruits joue à partir
immédiatement
mais comment voulez-vous sous les
papiers je les engueule ouais j'ai
écouté nous sommes kabarabe un pédalo le
vol
vous devez m'aider dans le travail pour
la résistance vous devez m'aider moi
même je pris un ton logique aux jeux
venant de et c'est moi qui en ai marre
cette forme ben ali ben bongo fils
lui-même en cuir et à 2 heures du matin
on les parties à faire en montant en jeu
plus exactement et les sous quel nom
vous voyez passer
voilà un nom qui était mon projet c'est
pas pire une petite pierre tombale vous
y avez le nom de ses commettants qataris
bri
alors elle a pris une longue peut la
regarder j 20 h f un lancement à la
vibro blanche alors par contre il ya un
truc
enfin je vous ferai un petit reproche
quand même parce que tant que vous
parlez de de vos aventures pendant la
guerre avant la guerre tout ça avait
alors quand vous racontez la publicité
je peux m'en la publicité c'est pas un
monde qui est très dur c'est un monde où
il ya des
des coups de force pour obtenir les
budgets parce que ce sont des budgets
importants il ya beaucoup d'argent à
gagner et vous raconter ça un peu comme
un comme un conte de fées dans tout un
conte de fées dans ma vie si vous ne
pouvez pas comme un conte de fées alors
que vous n'auriez pas aujourd'hui ouais
mais est ce que vous pensez pas que pour
les jeunes qui vont venir votre vie ça
serait bien quand même de le citer
quelques échecs de dire moi je me suis
fait une erreur en faisant ça je pense
que finalement c'est quand on lit vos
vies ce soit la rage de convaincre ou
les vous les mémoires d'un lion on a
l'impression que votre seul échec c'est
d'avoir pas rendu m6 soit il
vous avez bien dû avoir d'autres échecs
quand même je pensais pas que ça peut
aider les aider les jeunes de savoir
qu'on peut aussi se tromper vous pensez
pas que c'est un peu trop beau quand
même
jeuland la conseille aux jeunes un seul
ou sauter mais la vie il aime la vie des
déchets qui les voient pas eyal l autre
qui n'aiment pas les kilos et qu'en
voyant que les échecs on va d'échec en
échec on a compris ça quand on aime la
vie on va donner du sang dans les selles
grec se laver la tête c'est clair il
beaucoup les chèvres des lapins dormait
des drames des drames des pires et quand
on perd un enfant ressemble à quelqu'un
comment la famille les drames ça fait ce
qui vous marque pour la vie comme défi
catrice après l'opération qu'il faut
passer outre qu'il faut continuer quand
même
la vie est ainsi faite que film criminal
mais pas la vaincre
c'est elle qui vous avez regrette alors
quoi je ne peux pas vous faire un cours
sur ce que j'ai ressenti
j'ai passé par des moments épouvantable
d'ailleurs le serait choquant repas
quand il fallait les faire l'opération
bombardements où ça saute tous les côtés
les obus et vous sentez que vous êtes
pris le goût de ramener un équipage
quatre personnes avec un moteur en
flammes
tout ça je les fais est faux pas
trembler parce que vous avez cinq types
d'algues qui attend qu'on arrive tous
ensemble mais par exemple
il n'y a pas un mot dans votre bouquin
sur l'histoire de tv si c'est quand même
un truc qui n'a pas marché
pourquoi vous expliquer pas mais je
pense à pas marcher de façon à ce que
les jeunes qui lisent votre livre puisse
dire tiens quand je serais à la place de
marcel deschênes manche et je ferai pas
la même erreur alors tv fif on l'a
donnée oui après difficulté on nous l'a
même au fait qu'il foule prend way très
bien on a fait comme gpec radio fip et
en racontant et puis on l'a dit un jour
arrêté par un mystérieux soeur qu'est-ce
qu'on fasse faut comprendre chapeau et
un beau choix éclairé cela doit nous
habiter on a jamais reçus
mais si si vous avez continué tv ci
serait marché voyez vous croyez ça
aurait marché tv 6 à la sortie et tous
les jeunes qui font alors que prévu
comme ça il y avait déjà plein de jeunes
qui peut on avait fait que pour les
jeunes c'était quelque chose qui était
nous vous l'aurez voulu sortir
naturellement de ce que la bulle la 2 la
3 pourrait faire si on voulait avoir
pour nous comme derrag l'ophite et
raconte l'histoire qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai fait uniquement pour les
jeunes c'est à dire le chef est venue
d'amérique
j'avais un copain avec you will et 10
tchad alors qu'en france on ne savait
pas c'est que jazz
je ne fais pas fait pour 19/100 ce
vendredi dans 34 ouais les premiers
disques et j'ai eu tous les jeunes avec
moi clair qu'à ce moment là on en
connaît très mal le post est mauvais les
gosses ont pointé leurs parents parce
qu'il voulait entendre le tchad alors
que les parents où la mobilisation est
bien c'est ça qui a gagné la partie
parce qu'on commençait à travailler avec
des les postes à galène ou des postes
avec un minuscule joue entre la peine et
puis j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre
compte la puissance la radio je ne
raconte pas ce qu une aventure
extraordinaire
alors vous avez parlé de la publicité à
la radio la télévision à ce que vous
pensez pas quand même que maintenant sur
certaines chaînes y en a un peu trop
quand même
il en faut autant que puisse vivre un
poste si vous écoutez de préférence un
poste qui vous convient comment voulez
vous qu'ils vivent ils ne touchent pas
que c'est bon départ mais pour autant
qu'ils puissent vivre c'est une chose
mais après elle aurait cédé baigorri on
n'est pas des bombes bienfaiteur qui
doit avaliser pour toucher de l'argent
et la fondation de la vocation alors eh
bien c'est une belle histoire je pense
pour moi une belle histoire c'est ma
plus belle histoire quand on a et on
revient 30 ans l'arrière on arrive on
arrive à passer les pyrénées avec
michael duncan chef de réseau et en
arrivant sur le sol espagnol
on croyait tranquille on est très sale
angleterre toulon table on voit une
rivière merveilleux dont ceux de la
bigne on s'achète à l'eau et puis en
sortant d'art y vient on croyait battre
tranquillement passer le cap
il ya deux carabines espagnol qui nous
met on joue à poil on est rien et est
immédiatement embarqué en prison
hacquard fel de l'endroit qui était
épouvantable
et comme j'aime beaucoup de gens étaient
arrêtés des résistants des tout le monde
pas fait que vous pouvez je me suis
trouvé à 12 ans une cellule de deux je
sais pas si vous rendez compte
la vie épouvantables moralement
physiquement
physiologiquement pour tous que ce qui a
eu pour effet faire et il faut vite
parce que j'espère yoles et pendant
trois mois j'ai vécu vraiment qu un
animal comme une bête comme une bête car
pour faire ses besoins métiers détails
mais fait la tente de sortir à 1h page
et puis j'ai fait un rêve pas une
illusion mais réelle de fiel qui est
très bleu et je le dis et si je sors de
là je fais des choses pour un jeune mais
c'était un peu mieux quoi en disant je
m'accroche et moi même à l époque des
foires je ferai quelque chose savaient
pas quoi mais pour aider un jeune est
aujourd'hui à 750 jeunes un premier prix
et des 50 médecins il ya que j'ai fait
grâce à la vocation premier prix
puisqu'on les premiers rôles sans
connaître france on ne peut pas imaginer
je crois que ma vie c'est le plus aurait
plus jamais fait
fait 154 lits dans tous les domaines qui
sont les premiers leurs impôts moi c'est
une immense joie et votre successeur
êtes content trek j'ai fabriqué ouais
j'ai fabriqué elle veut dire vraiment
tel qu'il est les corrections de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus